bien sûr c'est très célèbre alors on
regarde ces extraits tout de suite ça je
vous le jure il faut se méfier des
familles parce que je vous ferai tout le
bénéfice alors bon vent et sa femme
paulette et m'économise au moins 10 kg
farine par jour tu as la châtre aussi
jeu laissera voir parce qu'elle a
disparu depuis trois jours en kz2
qu'elle est pas destiné aux cas de
sortie par le passé je me mets dans vos
losier il y attend de lièvre dans mon
champ comme le savon pluton fait on nous
demandera pas ta chatte
d'ailleurs je sais je sais où les partis
je sois je n'ai entendu raconter son
histoire là sur le toit quand ça ne leur
a pas servi un bar
ça ne pensais pas quand on est enfin
allé l'entrée du marquis tiens voilà
monsieur le marquis
je suis madame le marquis castan
devenait lé chef d'escadron à la
retraite mais pas ya un activité
c'est pour dire que je suis très
sensible madame à l'éclat de votre
visage et que je vous suis profondément
reconnaissant de bien vouloir être cyber
je suis dit je vais vous présenter mon
berger mm dominique seux de l'inité
tiendra le mercredi le samedi unis du
sac loyer pour prendre 30 points
il sait nous allons boulanger me faire
ses 30 points deux fois par semaine en
plus de temps pour les paupières et le
samedi et mercredi si tu avais une nous
aident les croissants ou des brioches
j'espère que cette ds ne verrait aucun
inconvénient les mettre en bourse a bien
eu lieu
monsieur marc marti voilà la femme du
boulanger